c'est ce qu'on appelle une provocation
frontale alors que des pompiers étaient
en train d'intervenir pour sauver une
personne dans une école à l'est de la
capitale un jeune homme s'est amusé à se
filmer en prenant à partie les
sauveteurs là les pompiers car on a tué
quelqu'un et à des pompiers de paris
missionné du paname jusqu'à ici pour
sauver une vie
joerres élève ses gants en latex dans
une succession de stories sur les
réseaux sociaux jeune homme qui se fait
appeler ryan n'a pas hésité à insulter
les sapeurs alors qu'ils étaient en
train de travailler kir encore pendant
qu'ils étaient à l'intérieur de l'école
le jeune homme s'est précipité dans leur
camion pour prendre des photos mais
aussi pour leur voler du matériel à la
nappe est à akwa dedans c'est quoi ça
en fermant maintenant créé depuis dédits
mal compromettant du jeune homme ont été
retrouvés sur les réseaux sociaux
interpellé quelques heures après les
faits le jeune homme ne serait resté que
vingt-quatre heures en garde à vue il
aurait écopé que d'un stage de
citoyenneté une sanction qui semble bien
faible comparé aux actes de vol et aux
différentes menaces proférées alors
intrusion dans un camion de pompier
menace l'auteur des faits est relâché
est ce un scandale
oui
est ce un scandale je voudrais d'abord
vous tourner vers midi là qu'est lâchera
rien alors il a tout jeune tout jeune
majeur eu bob pas plus de maximum vote
c'est un très bon patron alors
c'est plus complexe que ça mais c'est un
bon ami d'accord vous travaillez dans le
même nom alors on travaille sur la même
plate forme d'accord voilà met pas sur
le même type d'accord très bien alors
intrusion dans un couple vraiment de
pompiers menace l'auteur des faits
relâché tous très vite alors il a plein
qui ont crié au scandale est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est un scandale ou pas
éric broquaire nous porte parole des
sapeurs compléteront vous je sais que
vous avez été extrêmement
énervé par ces pics très belle très
énervé il faut le dire on a eu beaucoup
de messages de soutien de la part la
population qui trouve c'est intolérable
symboliquement il est allé toucher un
appareil un accessoire qui permet de
sauver des vies ça pas une canule diesel
tout simplement qui permet libérer des
voies aériennes et qui permet à tout un
chacun lorsqu'il s'étouffe de leur trône
la place correctement de continuer à
vivre et respirer donc là clairement on
touche aussi un symbole des sapeurs
pompiers qui est un véhicule les
agressions des sapeurs pompiers
il y en a tous les jours malheureusement
aujourd'hui c'est en dix ans et 213 %
d'augmentation et encore elles sont pas
tous déclaré parce que les pompiers
aujourd'hui sur un peu las de ce genre
de l'histoire est là j'ai envie de dire
que c'est ni plus ni moins que la
stupidité dans toute sa splendeur parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on touche une
ambulance c'est quelque part un moyen de
secours en moi et si aujourd'hui
nécessaire quand on voit qu'on est sous
tension en permanence ne serait ce que
par rapport aux crises naturelles que ce
soit par rapport aux crises terroristes
ou tout autre crise technologique et au
quotidien quand on touche une ambulance
et qu'on risque de l'endommager de la
volée quelque part c'est chez vous
peut-être qu'on pourra pas intervenir
vous savez c'est 6300 caserne en france
et à peu près là 35 36000 communes en
france donc vous imaginez qu'un maillage
territorial qui est assez important qui
sont couverts par des pompiers
volontaires et des pompiers
professionnels dont 80 % donnent de leur
temps quand il s'agit aujourd'hui de
partir en mission et ne pas retrouver
son environnement et le pire d'avoir
quelqu'un qui s'amusent je ne sais pas
dans quel monde on est en tout cas
aujourd'hui on a des images qui
montraient clairement que les sapeurs
pompiers on en a besoin comme toutes les
autres forces de secours et toutes les
autres forces de collectivités
territoriales parce que il exactement
j'aurais préféré un jeu permet de couper
l expliquer pourquoi tout à l'heure on
n'arrive pas à mettre un pompier sur
chaque personne lorsqu'une crise naturel
mais c'est parce qu'on a des méthodes on
a des stratégies la défense
d'anticipation plutôt que de venir de
déblatérer là dessus mais il faut le
faire parce qu'il faut faire prendre
conscience aux gens à un moment donné
que stop ça doit s'arrêter aujourd'hui
on est le dernier rempart j'étais déjà
venu changement si voilà pour lui
expliquer qu'il est temps de faire
nation qui attend d'être rangé du côté
du du service public aussi un moment
donné parce qu'il rend service tous les
jours éric dandenault et marc parfois
j'ai envie d'arrêter il ya plus de sens
quand on quand on en arrive à cette
situation là au regard de ce qu'on fait
au quotidien dont nous disposions de 113
% d'augmentation en disant on dit c'est
incroyable oui c'est incroyable comment
vous dites vous reconnaissez plus le
métier que vous aviez échoué ce sont un
moment donné une perte de repères nous
tarde de mission quand on constate cette
manière là donc heureusement que j'ai
envie de dire parfois il ya les réseaux
sociaux pour nous remercier quand on
voit des messages de voilà qui est
encourageant mais par des gens mine de
rien pour mercy ya d'autres moyens sur
le buzz voilà d'autres moyens de faire
le buzz en s'engageant il ya d'autres
points noirs le buzz en proposant ses
services auprès de la citoyenneté un
jeune homme a à ryan a le regard noir ce
soir par amine parce que bien mais là
rien à voir non mais ça juste avant
j'aimerais c'est très bien et je vais
vous demander à vous un peu d'attention
bien sûr avant de répondre à cette
question est-ce un scandale j'aimerais
que vous preniez le temps d'écouter ce
que je vais vous dire à première vue la
personne qui dirait non c'est pas un
scandale
pourrait traiter de fou sachez donc que
c'est moi qui a appelé les pompiers pour
venir à l'école je travaille dans cette
école ok j'ai sonné la même école que
vous ryan n'ont alors rien ne travaille
pas dans une école rien aimer les vols
qui était surveillant alors rien et
bénévoles encore une fois il faut pas
croire tout ce qu'on monte dans les
réseaux sociaux d'accord ryan et
bénévoles il intervient au sein de
différents établissements collèges
lycées centres jeunesse savons faire
sans trop s'y d'enfants handicapés ou
les bénévoles en difficulté
les bénévoles ils sont beaux en effet
parce que j'ai plusieurs témoignages de
parents d'élèves utile de parents
d'élèves qui qui peut vous dire qu'il a
fait du bien à pas mal d'enfants non
mais alors justement alors amine jour
est juste un truc parce que c'est vrai
que ce qui est paradoxal c'est que j'ai
enquêté un petit peu sur ryan et avec
les équipes aujourd'hui
ryan est bénévole dans une école il
s'occupe également d'enfants en
difficulté il est là donc c'est ça qui
est fou
c'est pourtant le dire parce que
justement ce que j'aimerais vous s'il
vous plaît ce que j'aime aussi ce temps
on ne défend pas mais s'il faut ou non
mais écoutez moi si ce n'est terminer
être humains complexes 1 exactement mais
j'ai encore foi en l'humanité ce qu'il a
fait ce qu'il a fait c'est une grosse
bêtise mais sachez qu'il n'ya eu aucun
vol et ça je peux en témoigner plusieurs
plusieurs enfants peuvent en témoigner
il a fait une blague de mauvais augure
qui est vraiment détestable également
veygoux événement lac entre mauvaise
très mauvaise image est mais sachez que
avant que les pompiers donc quand moi
j'appelle les pompiers et que j'ai une
j'ai une enfant qui est qui est en train
de perdre connaissance qui je vais pas
dévoiler la cause voilà pour pas mettre
en difficulté cet enfant mais à ce
moment là les pompiers me disent écoutez
il faut absolument que vous la mettre
maintenir éveillé ok la personne qui m'a
aidé à la maintenir à billère bien le
clown en faisant ses blagues habituelles
c'était qui s'était ryan ryan ils
étaient là avec moi il l'a maintenu
éveillé jusqu'à que les pompiers
viennent quand les pompiers sont venus
auquel les pompiers ont été aucunement
dérangé pendant leur travail ils ont
fait leur leur travail très très bien
d'ailleurs je les remercie ils ont été
très réactifs mais les pompiers font un
travail magnifique magnifique juste
magnifique c'est
la chose dont il a fait qui est mauvaise
et qui lui-même le reconnaît terrain
j'ai merdé je suis désolé c'est cette
vidéo ou alors il ya une autre vidéo
énormément parler j'y viens j'ai vu la
vidéo sur les policiers il y en a une
autre aussi sur l'élimination
d'associations a cédé on va la voir on
va l'avoir pour regarder cette vidéo qui
fait énormément parler comme ça tu nous
expliques
tu veux quoi et je vais aller mais c'est
rien à
l'envoi par bien est à bouche natiembé
bec à la tum à gaza un excellent chien
faites des affaires bande de chiens afin
dé j'arrive mettez tous vos gilets pare
balles voilà ça allait choco non mais
c'est rick donc là cette vidéo choquante
cette vidéo date c'est compliqué il ya
de plus de six mois ok ce qui s'est
passé après ce scandale la deux avec
officielle des eau il se moque des
jeunes ajustement de cité il n'a pas la
tête d'un terroriste il n'a pas le
regarder certaines 2 millions étaient
des terroristes sionistes c'est vrai je
suis d'accord mais je suis d'accord
histoire bien sûr à me
regarder ses vidéos voilà ce qu'il fait
c'est qui ce moque c'est maladroit ce
qui fait hockey et ça joue en sa
défaveur regardez la vidéo en entier
votre axe de défense c'est qu'en fait
vont vous sainte c'est un humoriste qui
a fait des mauvaises passes est pas un
acte de défense c'est pas du tout et
même de défense oui il en est lui-même
reconnaissait faut dix accords écoutez
j'ai fait une grosse bêtise mais c'est
la même chose que ce que vous faites
vous dans le vestiaire c'est la course
au buzz sauf que lui la différents moi
je veux
bien sûr et amusant et bien volé
personne et je me haci la volée non non
je ne me l'annoncer les jeux
en criant
sortie
j'ai un ami qui viennent et craint un an
vous avez bien ce que vous en pensez un
ami d'origine musulmane un très bon ami
à moi mes frères voilà je vous le dis je
suis tellement déçu du comportement leur
ce mec il n'est pas défendable force aux
pompiers l'ancienne salle il est
musulman je
réponde à ça ce qui fait ce qui fait ici
c'est lui-même et des sur ces deux
cibles un fait mais c'était dans une
c'était pas dans une intention de nuire
ou quoi que ce soit ça et même la
communauté musulmane aujourd'hui lui en
veut terriblement de cette vidéo mais ce
qui fait une liesse avaient pour thème
bien sûr l'agrément mais lui ce qu'il
fait à la base c'est qu'il se justement
il se joue des gens et qui parle comme
ça et c'est bien clément à la porsche à
michou via un truc aujourd'hui je
voudrais m'arrêter moi j'ai plein d'amis
musulmans qui vivent dans une détresse
incroyable bien sûr il ya deux il ya eu
yamaha que dans un racisme ordinaire
pour les musulmans qui est incroyable de
10 ans perdant de gens mais ça et je le
vois sur plein de plateaux de télé
talent je trouve que c'est devenu assez
maniable ils peuvent pas mettre
aujourd'hui une chaîne de toute la
journée regardez les ils sont tout
autant stigmatiser ils ont pour la
plupart envie juste de vivre normalement
de pouvoir vivre heureux en france et
aujourd'hui ça mais ça devient une
souffrance pour eux d'aller sur les
réseaux sociaux sadien souffrance pour
eux alors qu'à verizon et là je pense
qu'il fait énormément de mal surtout en
ce moment où je vous dis il ya plein de
musulmans tandis que cheryl on n'en peut
plus parce que aujourd'hui un racisme
ordinaire autour de nous on a juste
envie de vivre normalement et on se fait
attaquer l'euro toute la journée mais
c'est un cataclysme du couple
mais dites moi aujourd'hui acquis vers
foot aujourd'hui dans l'éducation
nationale à l'école on n'utilise pas on
nous apprend pas à utiliser les réseaux
sociaux auxquels les enfants
lui même bien sûr lui même dit j'assume
il est parti se rend de lui-même au
commissariat
ok elle est partie se vend entre les
maisons il est aigri
bien sûr et les parties donc il est
parti se rendre très bien et les parties
se rendent week-end on l'a laissé
repartir parce que justement après
enquête il s'avère qu'il n'a rien volé
moi c'est vous savez c'est moi qui ai
récupéré le sac ça veut dire que moi je
sors les pompiers donc avait la boule
verte
juste devant les pompiers dans la
voiture les pompiers le voit hockey
étant dit écoutez la porte est ouverte
regardez si vous manquerez et c'est un
des pompiers me dit je crois qu'il nous
manque un sac foule donc c'est
à ce moment là il était en train de
sortir mais les mecs moi je vais vous
dire mais c'est vrai dans les détails a
ajouté
eric je tiens juste à signer une chose
c'est que bon il ya eu deux des sujets
stigmatisation aujourd'hui les
agressions c'est dans tous les quartiers
c'est dans toutes les zones
pavillonnaires bien sûr que ça sent bien
voulu en vous mêmes tués malheureusement
paris malheureusement perdu leur job
dans un quartier tranquille
pavillonnaire ça arrive partout
aujourd'hui on a des présents
présentement qui sont effectués très
rapidement puisque dès lors qu
aujourd'hui on agresse à
sapeurs-pompiers une proposition de loi
matras va être votée par la commission
mixte paritaire dans quelques jours pour
plafonner justement et mettre à niveau
les sanctions auprès de c de ces
personnes agressives envers les sapeurs
pompiers au même niveau tout ce qu'ils
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
donc gérer ça c'est le premier point
deuxième chose c'est qu'au travers de
toutes ces agressions aujourd'hui a
quand même un exemple inverse a montré
ses dires bas pas de souci il ya un vsab
et enfin véhicule de secours aux
huitièmes à l'extérieur au lieu de jouer
à ça exactement le niveau de gain et le
ils reconnaissent au soyons quand on est
citoyen bien sûr emblématique de notre
service bien s'il reconnaît et redonner
cette cette erreur alors il veut
aujourd'hui lire homo homini lors qu'il
a les yeux les et il a mis salut ma team
je suis actuellement chez moi je ne suis
pas en prison je sais pas quoi voilà
j'ai fait une vidéo mise en scène avec
les pompiers aucun vol n'a été commis
les pompiers n'ont pas été dérangé
durant leur intervention suite ge est
accusé de terrorisme je me suis fait
remarquer aux yeux de ma famille je
pense que je n'ai pas à me justifier à
ce sujet il ya clairement diffamation et
volonté de me nuire clairement je
demande à riom amazing un match annoncé
pas et surtout ceux qui me suivent je
suis pas le meilleur exemple du monde
mais je ne suis pas une mauvaise
personne j'essaie de réussir dans la vie
pour ma maman avant tout pardon matile
je reviendrai permettez vous portez vous
bien l'influent d'équipé mettez vous
dans le jeu nous mettez vous dans la
peau d'un jeune de
ans et est papa de deux enfants de 5 à
20 ans est un homme mettez vous dans la
peau d'un jeune de 20 ans qui du jour au
lendemain se retrouve avec deux cent
mille abonnés sur snap qui se retrouve à
faire plusieurs millions de vidéos qui
devient bon là
ça ne l'excusé pour ce que je dis
l'énergie soit à moi qui me dit qu'il
est indéfendable c'est un autre pote à
la cccc monde dira mon ami moundir vrac
- il est très triste parce que voilà il
est triste de ce qui s'est passé on est
tous très tristes dit voilà on est tous
très tristes encore une fois je ne
défends pas sur ce qu'il a fait ce que
je veux que vous compreniez c'est que
aujourd'hui c'est pas que de sa faute
c'est la faute à tout
un jeune comme lui qui fait ça tout le
monde tout le monde en parle ok
aujourd'hui je suis prof ça fait depuis
2010 9,7 fois depuis le gym de prof de
physique-chimie et depuis 19 je
m'efforce à grâce à mes élèves qui m'ont
mis dedans non avant j'avais pas tous à
tous ces réseaux sociaux je fais des
contenu avec mes élèves donc à travers
les mangas qu'est leur passion ou à
travers les réseaux sociaux j'essaye de
les amener à apprécier la matière grise
et l'école ok je vais là je suis le seul
prof je crois si ce n'est pas dans le
monde on va dire l'europe qui fait des
lives en cours ok pour quelles raisons
pour que les jeunes puissent revoir le
live pour voir les leçons puis sauf si
je n'ai pas fait avoir dans les troubles
il s'est bien sûr ne pas avoir cette
phobie de l'école ok aussi aussi pour
les sensibiliser aux réseaux sociaux ce
qui s'est passé avec ryan c'est que quoi
il a fait une boulette si on lui avait
appris à manier ces eti mais c'est pas
les gens
vraiment élever ton ryan l'aï les
marchés on lui a pas appris qu'on
montera dans un camion de pompier pour
faire des doigts d'honneur sauter laisse
moi faire mieux laisser parler crier mal
élevés on vole pas les outils il a volé
des outils
ont été dépaysés factuellement quand on
regarde la vidéo il ya ce qui était
prévu alors si on attend c'est l'essai
par les simulations d'interventions
cardinal des sacs et qui vient de sauver
ta maman ouest une affaire bien sûr la
conception et c'est la foi de ton ryan
qui émanent en vainquant n'a rien à
[ __ ] des institutions diverses et qui
dit c'est une jour c'est qu'il doit y 10
des terres il dit allahou akbar il parle
de mieux sur ces très foot ou les
chez lui la faute aux musulmans dans la
vienne les gens qui sont musulmans ont
rien demandé qui font rien suisse lève
le matin qu'ils aillent bosser me plains
pas de réseaux sociaux pour ce mec là
c'est un petit con mal élevés je le dis
et j'assume
[Applaudissements]
deux batteries car
on va dans un camion de sa mue en jeep
le président on crache sur zemmour dans
la rue quand c'est tout le temps pareil
et à convient c'est pas de sa faute il a
20 ans quand il n'est pas jaloux on fait
des dix commandements et qui retarde
la culture catherine nationale fait pas
un film est aussi d'exprimer la table
toutes les motos de pompiers de
policiers s'est dit leningrad tout c'est
ok c'est toi qui peux arrêter pour ça
oui je ne les mettez des gilets
pare-balles c'est très grasse et se
servent
des cailloux c'est bien sûr il a été
arrêté pour savoir si telle est
conscient que les gens mais chaque on
n'a pas entendu la tue moi je m'étonne
beaucoup que vous veniez alors que
j'entends vos explications n'est que
vous placiez ça sous l'angle de l'humour
de la jeunesse les réseaux sociaux ne
sais pas ce que vous défausser sur un
certain nombre de choses finalement pour
vider la réalité de sa substance la
réalité c'est que ce type là la preuve
la première chose qu'ils insultent en
fait c'est sa communauté sa religion
bien sûr pourquoi parce que quand on
commet un vol ou quand on menace même
sous l'ère de la rigolade de vouloir
ainsi les gens en associant le nom
d'allah quand vous avez les aliments
vous savez que vous pouvez vous devez
pas faire ça exactement donc vous non
seulement ce type à 1 cc insulté lui
même a insulté la république à travers
les pompiers mais il a insulté aussi
l'islam et donc moi quand je dis que ces
gens-là ce type de personnes là d'accord
parce que la devise des pompiers s'est
arrêtée moi oui alors n'hésitez pas ça
dépend pas là en l'occurrence a été volé
et déguerpir pas sauvé paie rien mais si
vous voulez c'est ce type là c'est pour
ça que je les appelle les racailles
pourquoi parce que il faut distinguer
ces minorités malfaisante et nuisible du
reste de la population donc quand vous
avez des gens qui viennent défendre ces
jeux ces personnes-là ces délinquants là
parce que c'en est un d'accord au motif
qu'il est musulman banlieusards et ap
c'est eux qui amalgame tout le monde
avec ce genre de problème comment bien
sûr que vous avez vous savez pourquoi
maintenant je parle d'eux donc moi je
quand on m'accuse d'attiser la haine
jadis la haine contre ce type de
comportement parce que c'est
une autre vidéo qui fait beaucoup parler
lui aussi dans laquelle il insulte et
menace jean michel blanquer mon nouvel
ami et mini-jeux l'éducation nationale
alors regarde et regarde encore une
blague n'a pas de soucis on arrive vous
allez voir tamera blanc qui a aidé le
tout cas cela fait un bond de 6,2 qui
ont raté le bac
alors
nicolas
ramène le poké là qu'il a besoin pour
défendre ses sorties du contexte
non non je vous le dis
c'est pas défendent alors des plans
famille est jeune je ne défends pas mais
elle est choquante la vidéo sur toile
est sorti du contexte là il en plein
tournage il est en plein tournage d'une
série netflix chez pas quoi
et tournon d'une série pour netflix bien
sûr dans plusieurs je croyais qu aider
les enfants en difficulté et le fait
bénévolement sa lutte au sida police e
journée
il le fait bénévolement à sa route au
service taurian la peinture vous plaît
pour moi c'est triplement un scandale
c'est un scandale c'est un scandale de
simuler un vol c'est un scandale d'un
super ministre d'insulter les pompiers
c'est aussi un scandale parce que ces
images elle dessert on l'a dit les
jeunes musulmans et jean louis saez fait
régal de l'est de les commenter
aujourd'hui donc ça sinon
c'est un scandale parce que c'est un
influenceur il est suivi par des
centaines de milliers de jeunes très
jeunes et il ya plein de gens j'en suis
sûr malheureusement qui en voyant ça
veut dire ah bah c'est cool d'insulter
un pompier c'est cool de rigoler de
sable où il se marre comme celle où l'on
travaille à rien de rôle et je pense qui
donne une très mauvaise image et un très
mauvais exemple les sanctions que vous
auriez voulu loeb 12 j jprd vous êtes le
seul à maintenons donc je voudrais avoir
votre avis pourquoi vous dites que c'est
pas choquant le fait qu'ils étaient
relâchés qu'il est juste un stage à
faire j'ai essayé de défendre
l'indéfendable mais je vais faire avec
coeur en fête ryan il est dépassé vous
avez dit charmé tâche de plomb c'est un
pétage de plombs ryan il était déjà
prise il était inconnu des services de
police un coup d'accord il a été placé
en garde à vue par les autorités
compétentes relâché on a l'a pas mis en
examen il y aura peut-être d'autres
procédures les pompiers ont porté
plainte on verra ça s'instruit mais pour
le moment c'est une triple terrible
erreur de jeunesse ryan c'est quelqu'un
je me suis renseigné qui aide les autres
donc il a fait des conneries énorme mais
non le scandale s'il est relaxé ça veut
dire quoi voulez qu'elle aille en prix
on voulait que sa vie soit brisée oui
mais moi non mais ça c'est rudy jeudi
c'est une erreur votre toit est super il
a essaimé 31 ans l'ancien banlieusard et
musulman messi a tout de suite il s'est
amusé
le sac qu'il a pris il l'a déposée pour
que vous le trouviez il viable à le
prendre bien sûr qu'on ne touche pas aux
pompiers vous est sacrée mais lui si
vous le faites payer là vous allez brisé
sa vie non pas de citoyenneté c'est pour
la rédemption si tu le sais pas payer la
livraison plus graves
sont actuellement elle sort ils disent
non justement parce qu'effectivement le
plus grave avec les gens ça parce que
c'est un stage de citoyenneté ces cinq
jours dans une mairie a parlé à des gens
institutionnel c'est à dire un maire un
policier ces cinq jours ou sept jours
maximum
mais comment expliquer aux jeunes que ce
qu'il a fait c'est très très grave
quand tu l'as en assumant ses cinq jours
dans une mairie a discuté du mal que tu
as fait mais il est là prend la fonction
c'est pas que s'éclaircit aujourd'hui
les lyncher son magret s'affûter sur les
réseaux les hackers bc des grisons ils
ont du mal à sa mère l'état de sa mère
moi j'ai vu sa mère au téléphone avant
de venir ok on m'a dit non on n'y va pas
on n'y va pas j'ai reçu plein de
messages aussi sur des désabonner et
c'est qu'une dizaine il va pas ne va pas
mais c'était ça mais c'est très
courageux de votre part d'être ça
m'était impossible je encore une fois je
ne défend pas ses actes ok je défends ce
qui arrive après c'est une erreur de
jeunesse qui mérite sanction la justice
française a très bien fait son travail
l'a arrêté il a été auditionné et il ya
une enquête qui a été fait non au final
il a été relâché hockey et il est puni
l'a eu
avec une amende mais parce qu'en france
la juste un monde la justice ne juge pas
ces jeux la société mais j'aime faire la
même
victime
c'est votre c'est le rien il ya neuf ans
ont été victimes d'inégalités de
discrimination mais c'est là un jour on
le libère c'est le moi mais tu es un mec
des beaux quartiers qui aurait fait ça
et baye aurait rien en prison dorée
érection plat éric broquaire dont vous
entendez tout ça les sanctions elles
sont donnés par des gens qui
effectivement donne des sanctions verdon
exactement et c'est pour ça que le pénal
et là aussi c'est parce qu'elles sont
jugées entre homme et avec l'aide
d'autres personnes aussi exact donc
effectivement un moment donné on
souhaite qu'il y ait un moment donné à
un système qui permette unis fait ça
mais c'est pas possible d'où l'intérêt
de porter ça dans une proposition
doivent bientôt pour mettre au même
niveau que l'autorité plus exact
dépositaire comme je vous l'aï dit tout
à l'heure mais un an à terme de sanction
il faut savoir que effectivement les
sapeurs pompiers aujourd'hui font déjà
de la citoyenneté auprès des citoyens
c'est-à-dire qui permettent à un moment
donné à des jeunes de tous les univers
que ce soit des classes dans les beaux
quartiers les moins quartier les
quartiers les plus défavorisés de les
sensibiliser de venir voir faire
comprendre nos missions la réalité de
nos missions donc ça se passe et le gard
le département du gard est très actif
dans la matière les alpes-maritimes
aussi où ils vont systématiquement
régulièrement dans tous les quartiers et
je dis bien tous les quartiers pour
sensibiliser les plus jeunes face à
l'affluence des réseaux sociaux de ce
qui se passe et pour normand aujourd'hui
ce que j'ai appris un dernier point
c'est que dès lors qu'on fait ces stages
mobilise du personnel et pendant qu'on
m'oublie celle là on a des seins sur
tendue en opération et aujourd'hui si on
parle derrière des inondations on y
parle de faire appel à des sapins
version est en permanence il avait alors
moi est ce scandale parfaitement oui le
monsieur honnêtement faut être débile
pour faire ça est-ce qu'il faut
l'incarcérer ballon six ans mais
incarcérer tous les crétins qui font des
trucs sur tik tok et où on va pas jamais
s'en sortir est ce que c'est pour qu'il
soit riche et oui est ce que je suis
pour qu'éventuellement il un bracelet
électronique pendant quinze jours trois
semaines oui et mathieu a parfaitement
raison les bons trucs de citoyenneté a
servi en tant qu'anglais
une
500c masse de ma soeur elle me dit
comment on en est arrivé là sérieux
c'est ça la vraie question est assez des
résultats
aujourd'hui regardez c'est le surf c'est
le surf sur le buzz si aujourd'hui par
exemple j'ai été appelé aujourd'hui pour
justement cette histoire ce scandale
j'ai pas été appelé parce que j'ai des
milliers d'abonnés et que je donne des
cours sur les résidents
parce que les socios s'exercent
en allemagne
est pas aussi nombreux
les acteurs s'il vous plaît merci oui à
94 % oui et vilaine roissy l'incessant